Hi, my name's Connor Miller. Today we
are at the Early Ford V8 Museum and we
are with a bunch of the 2026 X Cup
racers. We will be going over the
Timewise 825 speedometer, what comes in
it and how to install it. Hi, my name is
Aidan Cake.
Here is the user's manual, which is
going to be the first thing you're going
to pull out of your box from Timewise
and this is going to go over all the
stuff we'll go over today.
The next thing you're going to pull out
is your Timewise speedometer, which
you'll use throughout the whole race.
Hi, my name is Jackson Sintay. I'm with
Alpha State. Second thing you're going
to get in your box is this included this
year and you're also going to get that
with the Alpha magnets. You're going to
want to put these magnets on your wheel
mounted in here
and then you're going to route this from
your speedometer here all the way down
to your wheel something like this.
Hi, my name is Calvin. I'm also with
Alpha State.
Uh the last thing you're going to get in
your kit is this power supply. Um you
can hook it up to any ground in your car
or any 12-V supply. All right.
Now that we've shown you the
speedometer, we'll show you how to mount
it on the car.
All right, now we are down here at the
wheel. We will be explaining how to run
your transducer and how to mount your
magnets.
So, once you have your vehicle jacked up
off the ground safely and you have the
wheel off,
you're going to take your transducer and
route it in a way that it won't be
caught in any road debris. You're going
to mount that down from your
speedometer.
You're going to want to mount it to your
tie rod end on the knuckle here. So,
that way when the wheel turns, they will
turn with it and you won't get a messed
up reading or just a loose speedometer.
When you're mounting it, this is all
adjustable here. You're going to want
the distance between where this flat
surface is and your magnet on your yoke
to be about 3/8 to 5/8 of an inch or we
use just three popsicle popsicle sticks
glued together
and put them in between like that. Also,
if you're having an issue with the
readings on the speedometer while you're
driving or just after that, make sure
this surface is clean or it could get a
messed up reading from this back.
The next thing that we'll be talking
about is mounting the magnets on the
wheel. As long as the magnet is on a
portion of the wheel that will spin,
whether that's a brake drum or
internal to the rotor, it doesn't matter
because it's counting the rotations. We
choose to do it on the wheel because
it's easier to do rather than taking
your hub apart and it's easier to
troubleshoot. If your speedometer is not
reading, you'll be able to tell pretty
easily if you have your magnets.
We mount two magnets, which is standard
practice, so that every revolution
counts two pulses. You'll want to clean
the rim
and epoxy it with JB Weld or any kind of
uh um any kind of
stuff that will keep it
or avoid the heat.
So, the magnets don't get thrown off in
the middle of the day.
The other thing that the book says that
you can do is mounting it on the drive
shaft. We try to avoid that because it
will get thrown off. It's higher
revolutions and it's only one magnet, so
it's not as uh precise. Also, you'll
want to mount it on the inside non-drive
wheel. So, if your car is a rear-wheel
drive, you'll mount it on the front uh
driver side
so that you're not spinning the wheel
and getting inaccurate readings. All
right, now we're working on plugging the
speedometer in. This car has the battery
behind the passenger seat, but it's the
same whether your car's your battery's
in the trunk, under the hood, whatever.
So, here in the back of this '46 Ford,
we have our car battery, our 12-V car
battery, actually in the in the inside
of the car. Um it doesn't really matter
if the car or the battery is in the
inside or underneath your hood, you can
hook it up either way. So, in your
Timewise kit, you're going to get your
power supply. Uh you've got your
positive or negative side and your
positive side and you're going to hook
up these little gold loops directly to
your battery. You can see here that we
already have one hooked up. This is our
negative terminal, and this is our
positive. And then
on the other side of that power supply,
you're going to connect that directly to
your speedometer like so. That way you
get an accurate reading,
and you can track your speed.
As you can see, we hooked the Timewise
speedometer straight up to the battery
terminals. In the manual, it says that
you need an auxiliary battery. We've
never had issues with it draining the
battery down. As long as you unhook it
overnight, you can leave it hooked in
for a lunch stop or dinner stop, and
won't have any issues. The other thing
to know is that this is a 12-V battery.
This speedometer can only run off 12 V.
If you have a 6-V battery, you will have
to do something else to power this
speedometer. All right, now we are going
to look at mounting the speedometer and
what you need to be able to do every
day.
Hey guys, just wanted to talk about the
uh way you're going to mount your
speedometer inside the car. You're going
to want to make sure the speedometer is
easy to read and you know, easy to see
while you're driving down the road such
as this one over here. You're also going
to want to make sure the speedometer is
easy to remove, as you're going to have
to be able to unplug and plug in the
transducer cable, and adjust the factors
on the back of the speedometer from a
day-to-day basis.
Timewise does not come with a standard
mount in every speedometer. That's kind
of up to you to figure out. As you can
see, this one is a nice 3D printed one,
but a 4-in piece of PVC also works for
sliding your speedometer in and out of.
Uh this makes it easy so that you can
rotate it if you need to, or pulling it
in and out every day to plug in in the
transducer along with moving your
factor, or checking any of that.
Now, mounting it to your column or your
dash or wherever you want it is still
going to be up to you, but this gives
you a pretty good start. And some final
tips, if your speedometer is jumping
around, you've probably lost power. You
need to check that 15 amp inline fuse or
check the hookup to the either the
battery or the speedometer.
Another thing is the 4-in PVC mounts.
And also, if you come to a complete stop
and your speedometer is reading wrong,
you're going to take this face plate
here off
and spin the needle back clockwise
because you've lost power.
If you're getting readings that are
about half of your actual speed or just
no speed at all, you might be missing
one or both of your magnets on your rims
or you might have a dirty transducer or
just a broken or messed up one.
We also highly recommend that you do not
attach your magnets to your drive shaft
or your drive wheels. Specifically at
your drive wheels, if you're hot rodder
and you're like, you know, going pedal
to the metal, you'll be spinning those
tires in the rear and you won't be
getting an accurate reading.